he was an indispensable member of NATO
in my view its relationship to NATO was
fundamentally altered by Turkey's
support to the Islamic state and other
jihadi groups by its unwillingness to
allow in sheerluck Air Force Base to be
used by US and coalition air forces to
strike against the Islamic state and by
the slow response of Turkey to provide
training facilities for Arab Sunni
fighters who the u.s. envisioned on the
front line so I would dispute the the
premise of your question a turkey is a
indispensable member of NATO there are
strict criteria for getting into NATO
but there is no process for evicting a
member of NATO as I said before if
turkey if NATO were established today
turkey wouldn't qualify because of its
hostility to democracy rights and
support for Islamism so NATO is going to
evolve in my view what will happen in
the next year or two the eastern flank
of NATO will move from eastern Turkey to
Iraqi Kurdistan the air base in Erbil
will be the forward air station used by
coalition forces in the region the Iraqi
Kurds will hold a referendum on
independence they will negotiate a
friendly divorce agreement with Baghdad
and the US will be one of the first
countries to recognize it turkey will
also find that it's in Turkey's national
interests to cooperate with Iraqi Kurds
largely because of the large volume of
oil and gas which is shipped from Kirkuk
and north of Seoul ammonia to
the eastern Mediterranean port of Jhon
and as Iraq becomes increasingly
radicalized and led by Shiite extremists
with ties to Iran's Revolutionary Guard
Turkey might actually look at the Iraqi
Kurds as a welcomed buffer between
shiite-led Iraq and itself but NATO is
going to evolve we've already heard from
President Trump a willingness to Reeve
is NATO in my view revision NATO
recognizes Turkey as it is not for how
it was or how we wish it to be and
corresponding steps to extend the
eastern flank of NATO from in sheer
llyich and the entire surroundings into
Iraqi Kurdistan yeah just take another
1xg bow in the back you George also
student here at Harriman how strong in
your view is Iran's commitment to deal
with the EU about the immigration about
the refugees who might become immigrants
especially in the view of the upcoming
elections in Germany and France that can
be put into turmoil with with huge waves
of new immigrants it's a good question
we haven't discussed Turkish EU
relations or in the revolution so it's
an important question everyone rightly
says that the EU is constantly shifting
the goalposts the the eu-turkey deal on
migration had two components there were
six billion dollars that the EU is going
to pay turkey and I think it's been
dribbling out some sums to assist with
the refugees in Turkey
by the way who were created by conflicts
supported by Turkey through its
assistance to jihadi groups the other
component of the deal involved visa
liberalisation for Turkey with the EU so
it's easy for the EU to come up with six
billion euros and pay off turkey it's
much harder for the EU
to suddenly throw open its borders a la
visa liberalisation especially since
many of the Syrians who have ended up in
Turkey and who may have extremist
backgrounds our ACTRA are actually
security threats to EU Member States
so in my view there is ZERO prospect
that the EU is gonna provide visa
liberalisation to Turkey there's always
been a racist tendency amongst northern
europeans towards Turkey and that's
stronger today than ever before and my
question is you know why suddenly two
summers ago were there more than a
million refugees who took flight from
Turkey and decided that they wanted to
go to Denmark or to Germany rather than
stay where they were partly it's because
they had a futility about ever being
able to go home I think we have to
acknowledge that but I wonder what
conditions were going on in the camps
and the treatment of asylum seekers who
were denied work permits by turkey that
created a desire for them to leave
Turkey at great hazard set sail to
Greece which turned into a warehouse for
refugees and seek a brighter future in
northern Europe which has shown itself
to be deeply hostile towards immigrants
so there are a lot of unanswered
questions in my view the fact that the
eu-turkey deal on migrants has held so
far is remarkable I don't think it
endures mostly because the visa
liberalisation side of the deal has no
prospect of being implemented yeah let's
take a question here in the front yep
and just wait for the microphone thank
you
Rudolph Houser retire question I have
relates to some reports that I've seen
in the service that I've sometimes found
useful but other times it's like raw
intelligence not accurate that's namely
the intelligence service that Israeli
service deaf go and they were reporting
in the era after the election the u.s.
election had before the inauguration
that Trump Russia and Turkey had come to
an arrangement to divide Syria into
three zones and to push out Hezbollah
and the Iranian forces then they
followed this up which is not typical of
the other reports I've seen it turned
out not to be reliable with indications
that with the pressure on Trump because
of the undisclosed contacts with Russia
that this whole that salad and that
Trump realized he couldn't go along with
this anymore and this was falling apart
have you heard anything that would
confirm that what do you make of it if
you think that it's all credible and
this recent meeting that you refer to
which episode of characterized as a
means to avoid having those Russian back
forces and us back forces fighting one
another is that just to avoid that on
the battlefield other than that raised
the prospect that there might be future
negotiations along those formalise so
keep in mind there are two multilateral
tracks that are going on one will call
the Astana track and that's really about
a ceasefire about D conflicting and
Russia and Turkey did come together and
agree to terms of a ceasefire and in
some areas that ceasefire has been
implemented much to the benefit of
war-weary
Syrians the second track will call the
Geneva process and those are political
negotiations about the future of Syria
and we may have seen some small steps on
a stop
the geneva track is still stalemated the
idea that we would divvy up Syria into
three parts sounds an awful lot like
what great powers have done in the
Middle East's previously I'm not sure
that you can replace Sykes and picot for
Putin and air21 but clearly drawing a
map on the back of an envelope in which
powers are distributed is not an
effective peacemaking or negotiation
strategy and besides it doesn't address
the fate of four to five million Kurds
in Syria who are America's allies and
who have proven our best and most
reliable friends so what are we going to
do with them now I wouldn't be surprised
if the Kurds in Syria got dealt out
actually in 1975 the u.s. negotiated the
Algiers Accords and dealt out the Kurds
at that point in 1991 we urged them to
rise up against Saddam and then refused
to support them so there is historical
precedent for the u.s. abandoning the
Kurds but frankly the world has changed
the Kurds are no longer just a stateless
people who are victims the Kurds in
Syria are an army with 40,000 men and
women under arms working side-by-side
with US Special Forces so coming up with
a political solution that divvies up the
country in three parts isn't something
that you can do on the back of an
envelope it's going to require a serious
negotiation about a constitutional
arrangement for Syria and in my vision
the arrangement is going to look a lot
like the Dayton Accords did for Bosnia
you're going to have regions where local
groups some of those with military
capabilities are responsible for
security for governance for development
and humanitarian affairs
there will be some connection to
Damascus because Assad has made it clear
that he's not moving to Riyadh anytime
soon or to Tehran any time soon
so we're gonna have to figure out what
kind of power Charon is going to work
for Syria and you can't have power
sharing if you're not going to include
the Syrian Kurds as one of the
beneficiaries of a devolution of powers
agreement that's why US leadership is so
important in these negotiations you know
the Russians and the Turks can do Astana
if they want but when it comes to viable
durable peacemaking the US needs to have
a seat at the table when it comes to
enforcing a peace agreement the US needs
to play a role in tandem with its allies
and with the UN so the US can't just
step back and let Russia and Turkey take
care of it now that's a formula for
continued violent conflict let's take
another one right behind that gentleman
then we'll continue just wait for the
microphones you could thank you I have
two simple-minded questions the first is
do you have any thoughts on what happens
between Israel and Turkey from here
and the second simple-minded question is
what happened to Turkey
if erawan passes from the scene as there
are reports that he does suffer from a
serious illness so remember that turkey
israel relations were extremely
cooperative up until the Mavi Marmara
incident of 2008 when turkey sponsored a
humanitarian convoy to go to Gaza and
break the embargo when Israeli Defense
Forces board of the convoy and there and
they were attacked by persons on the
Mavi Marmara there were subsequently
nine people killed including one u.s.
citizen Turkey responded by breaking off
relations with Israel canceling weapons
procurement deals Israeli tourists
coming to Turkey took a nosedive just
recently with everyone sending a letter
to Netanyahu we've seen some improvement
in the Israel turkey relationship but
here again this is not something that
profoundly affects the relationship
Israelis and air Dewan won't forget
statements that Israelis and Netanyahu
won't forget statements that air Dhawan
made calling the treatment of
Palestinians a genocide so there is a
small improvement in relations but here
again it's a shallow transactional
arrangement and the second part of your
question a turkey post or two one
what what would be the prospects I guess
and then just to build on that know
taking stock of the legacy and the
changes what would Turkish government
look like without her Diwan as a figure
so I had a conversation with a former US
ambassador to Turkey I asked him what
can we do to help turkey through this
transition and you know what he told me
assassinate air21 I was shocked because
I've never heard a former US officials
say anything like that
it shows the deep degree of enmity and
distrust
that exists between the United States
and Turkey today and frankly I don't
think that the u.s. is going to
contemplate such a move but I would
agree with you that air to one's days
are numbered it's not because of his
colon cancer or whatever he's got it's
because somebody in his inner circle is
going to pull up put a bullet in his
brain and put Turkey out of its misery
under everyone's dictatorship then what
happens
turkey is a deeply divided country there
are red and there are blue states blue
provinces will there be widespread
violence we don't know I can't say what
we do know is that the way to democracy
is not through a coup the way to
political transition is not through
assassination
if Turks are serious about restoring
their democracy that starts on April
16th with the vote authorizing turkeys
new executive authoritarian Constitution
and from what I hear a majority of Turks
oppose it is there any chance that
everyone is going to allow Turks to vote
down the constitutional change
establishing his great powers I don't
think so
and it reminds me of something that
Hafez al-assad said after an election in
Syria
he got ninety nine point three percent
of the vote he was asked your excellency
how do you feel about today's election
and his response I want to know who was
the point seven percent so you're the
ones not going to take any prisoners
he's going to make sure he wins this it
will cast further doubt on his
credibility it will further destabilize
Turkey it will further undermine the
u.s. turkey partnership but your policy
recommendation is stilts the
constitutional means that have to be
probed at all costs we've gone through
so the constitutional means being
rejecting the constitutional reform that
would institutionalize the dictatorship
I'm not sure that's possible I'm not
sure that
air21 would allow it as somebody who
works on human rights and peace building
I'm profoundly opposed to coup d'etats
or political assassinations so let me
just say clearly for the record I don't
see the path to democracy in Turkey
running through that kind of action but
the Turkish people are noble part of the
reason that I've been to Turkey 40 times
is because I have so many friends with
whom I had great respect and whom I
admire greatly I feel that the majority
of Turks want to restore Turkey's
pro-western ties and the country's
greatness that can't happen with air21
as the chief executive we have time for
one more question yes sir from your
vagina booties advisor Alexander begin
was reported to be in Turkey a day
before the coup meeting with doe parent
check and some ATP people and just after
the coup over 160 tornado and Western
generals were fight or perched what do
you think about this and he's even put
in the moment after the matter of to
cook so I've read or heard of your
excellent writing about Aaron's
complicity with the coup plotters I've
also read your excellent writings about
Isis links to air to one's government
and MIT I'm afraid it's just simply
above my paygrade to speculate why
Russian generals were an anchor of the
day before the coup if you connect the
dots it looks a lot like they were
talking about security strategies that
they were putting list together of
pro-western generals and security
officials who would be purged thereafter
but I don't have any authoritative
source that would tell me that is fact I
do have in my book anonymous references
from senior AKP official from a senior
police and intelligence officials of
the degree of criminality that exists in
the AKP and the Turkish government but
for all the obvious reasons those
persons wouldn't allow me to attribute
the information to them because they
would be dead as with their family
members who would otherwise be in jail
so I I wrote this book because I
strongly believe that the u.s. turkey
relationship is critical to the United
States that NATO as a security
partnership has proven itself a turkey
has shown an indispensable commitment to
NATO I'm horrified at the turn of events
its impact on US interests the effect
that it has on Turkish citizens you know
Fulbright Scholars who have been here
now can't go back to Turkey the emails I
get every day from people who are
lamenting the crackdown and the impact
on their lives so I hope that we can
restore Turkey has a gold standard of
democracy a turkey would take that the
new turkey would take steps to resolve
its differences with the Kurds in Turkey
that it would acknowledge the Armenian
Genocide and work towards a resolution
of relations with other minorities
including reopening the hockey seminary
there's a lot that turkey can do to put
itself back on track it's time for
straight talk and an adult relationship
I've written this book because I want to
contribute to that conversation yeah
David that's I think that's a great way
to end so just a reminder David will
linger and sign some books and take your
informal questions the book is an
uncertain ally Turkey under Iran's
dictatorship the author is David
Phillips David thank you for joining us
[Applause]
how do I sign it on that guy
okay also UNC Wilmington and all where
they are currently holding their
editorial meeting for their upcoming
anthology when the class is over
director Emily Smith is going to speak
with us about the publishing Wow
in the creative writing Department
somebody suggested this last week and I
can remember was that I loved it the
idea that the nonfiction pieces have the
little synopsis right in the TOC yeah
what if we borrowed that for the
anthology Simone equivalence even if it
rolls from one page to the next page you
would see a little snippet about each of
those 16 essay it's equal to get for an
anthology - that's gonna make you pick
it up and flip to something absolutely
today we were in the look out practicum
which is one of our graduate courses
when students can come in they're
actually pop by on their part of the
staff of look out books so they are
helping me with all of the pieces that
are part of the publishing process so
editorial which is what we were doing
today we are publishing anthology of
essays written by women who've appeared
in the pages of ecotone the department
of creative writings in-house literary
magazine so lookout was founded in 2009
but we published our first book in 2011
which was Edith Pullman's I knew in
selected short stories it was called his
called binocular vision we published a
title or two a year so every year since
then we've been putting out story
collections debut novels essay
collections poetry collections this is
going to be our second anthology that's
coming out in 2018 and though the
mission of that small press is to
publish historically underrepresented
authors debut authors and overlooked
gems so the students are part of our
staff and every week get together to
help contribute to one of those pieces
of the publishing process look how books
is just one of several entities that
fall under the auspices of something we
call the publishing laboratory it's part
of the creative department of creative
writing at the University of North
Carolina Wilmington it was founded in
2000 under the visionary guidance of my
predecessor Stanley Kolbert who retired
to this area was the former CFO of
HarperCollins Canada he was also the
producer of Fraggle Rock and flipper so
a really interesting colorful background
with a lot of experience and expertise
so he founded the public here the idea
being to sort of pull back the curtain
on the publishing process for our
writers here in the back
there's a fine arts program and creative
writing and also the master's program in
creative writing so that they would have
the tools to pitch their work to
publishers to put together book
proposals query letters so that they can
understand a little bit about the
typesetting process of the book design
process the marketing and promotion and
distribution so what he brought in was
an in-house bindery so it's a small
perfect binder and a guillotine trimmer
students started making their own small
run books whether those were chat books
sort of a limited a sample if you will
of their longer theses projects and
which is a fine artistic tradition in
its own right producing chat books so
that was founded like I said in 2001 and
then it's grown over time too it's now a
sixteen station desktop publishing
facility and under the auspices of the
publishing laboratory we have Chautauqua
literary magazine which is a complement
to the Chautauqua Institute in New York
we also have ecotone magazine that I
mentioned was founded in 2005 by David
Gesner who's currently the chair of the
creative writing Department and then we
also like I said founded look out in
2009 and have brought out now seven
titles under the literary imprint
Lookout books so you've got a small
prescient house you've got two literary
magazines in house and students in our
bachelors program and our master's
program can participate fully in the
publishing process and all the different
aspects that it takes to bring a book
and magazines into the world I imagine
you would design it I mean if I if it
was like oh I think a tight treat that's
like
typography would be best to represent
this you're basically creating like a
version of an art brief for example when
we sent or a design brief when I write
to all the freelancers whether they're
working as just like a cover designer or
a sort an illustrator for a specific
thing or I'm writing to them even if I'm
writing to an during one thing we like
to use this I'm giving an example of how
the practicum courses meet once a week
for three hours and like I said they
function mostly as a staff meeting
people reporting on various things
things that they've been working on in
the class and once a week then they're
also sub meeting so you will have the
group of the genre editors will meet
independently during the week same thing
the design team might to get to get
together you heard me in class today
saying no between now and this time next
week I want all the interior designers
to get together and put together some
samples that we can review as a group
next week
students when they start out are often
very intimidated by that idea of
publishing or publishers are the big
scary evil you know they're the ones
saying no and so I think that having
students really learn about publishers
and what we do and what we bring to a
manuscript that we're making a financial
investment in a manuscript that we're
bringing all of our design resources our
editorial resources and capabilities to
make that book the best it can possibly
be and then to help it find its
readership you know a book in my mind is
not finished until it finds its audience
so that's really what I'm trying to help
them see the publishing process is an
artistic process and publishers and
editors and book designers even
marketers as artists - that are part of
this larger publishing publishing entity
one of the things that's been most
exciting is that students are now going
out and founding their own impressive
Asst and founding their their own
literary magazines and that's been
really rewarding to see that they are
finding the gaps in literary publishing
or they're finding the places where we
really need a publisher that does this
and they now have all the tools and
resources to be able to do that also for
my writers they're learning through the
publishing process
find the right home for their work so
they're learning about all of these
small independent presses around the
country alongside the big five
publishers and really I think finding a
better compliment for their work they're
learning how to find the right agent and
also learning something of the
behind-the-scenes process so I think
that they will have will certainly be
authors who have a greater respect for
the publishing process and for all of
the artists with whom they'll work as
part of bringing their book into the
world
see spam where history unfolds daily in
1979 c-span was created as a public
service by America's cable television
companies and is brought to you today by
your cable or satellite provider
and in the times that day was a piece
that blew my mind it was one of those
stories that you read and you don't
forget and it was it was in the National
section and the headline was something
to the effect of Mexican cartel lures
American teens as killers and it was an
article about these boys from Laredo
Texas which is right on the border with
Mexico the boys names were Gabriel
Cardona and Rizal yo Rhetta Rizzoli I
went by Bart because he was five three
and looked a lot like Bart Simpson
and they worked with other boys in
Laredo and they'd all become operatives
for a very dangerous drug cartel called
the Zetas and so the article talked
about them talked about their crimes and
mentioned a Laredo detective a man by
the name of Robert Garcia who had
pursued these boys when the cartel sent
them back into the u.s. to start to do
murders on this side of the border on
behalf of the cartel I'm not gonna read
from the book today I actually don't
even have a copy but I did just want to
read the first few lines of this piece
because it's what got me started on this
book and it's what this sort of seed of
wolf boys was so here's here's how that
piece began it was written by a guy
named James C McKinley Jr who's who's a
veteran New York Times reporter at that
point he was he was on the southwest
border and he went to Laredo to write
the story that I read this is how it
starts when he was finally caught Rizal
yo Rhetta told detectives here that he
had felt a thrill each time he killed it
was like being Superman or James Bond he
said I like what I do
he told the police and the videotaped
confession I don't deny it
mr. reto is 13 when he was recruited by
the Zetas he was one of a group of
American teenagers from the impoverished
streets of Laredo who was lured into the
drug wars across the Rio Grande in
Mexico with promises of hype a fancy
cars and sexy women
after a short apprenticeship in Mexico
the young men lived in an expensive
house in Texas available to kill
whenever called on you can watch this
and other programs online at book tv.org
even morning everybody this room got
really quiet really fast good morning
everybody
hi welcome to the 2017 Ronald Reagan
Student Leadership Program excuse me
reunion we are honored to have you here
today
we have students from our pilot summer
2013 in the audience 2014 2015 somewhere
in there 2016 that's usually the case I
would like to open this morning's event
with the Pledge of Allegiance so please
join me I pledge allegiance my name is
ELISA Whitely for those of you that
don't know me and I'm the Associate
Director of Education for school
programs here at the library for those
of you who have been attending the
reunion each year since the program was
officially launched you know this is our
third convening in the past we have
brought you amazing speakers through our
panel of students who have impressed us
with their stories of trials challenges
changes in direction and ultimate
success in their leadership action plan
many of those students are in the
audience today last year as many of you
may know the normally celebrated reunion
was marked with a touch of sadness as it
fell just two days after mrs. Reagan's
funeral after closing the museum for a
full week so the public could pay their
respects and canceling all other
scheduled tours and events for her
beautiful ceremony the student
leadership reunion just happened to be
the only event that was allowed to go on
that week roughly one year ago if you
ask me I think someone was looking out
for us that day in an effort to always
challenge ourselves to find new
opportunities to support our program
alumni along your leadership journey
today's event is a little different than
we have done in the past for those of
you or maybe all of us in this room who
have ever wondered who was Ronald Reagan
not what did he accomplish or how did he
change the world but who is Ronald
Reagan the man who was the person away
from the photos the statues the
interviews and the many other dimensions
the public sees reading Peggy Randy's
book the president will see you now you
can't help but feel you are brought in
closer to Ronald Reagan and the person
he truly was today we invite you to
learn more about what it really means to
be a leader from someone who worked
alongside this great man for 10 years
please join me in welcoming our keynote
speaker Peggy
Randi thank you so much for having me
here today
what a pleasure what a beautiful day at
the Reagan Library not that there's an
ugly day up here but this is truly a
beautiful day and I'm so grateful for
the invitation for Melissa to be here
today I'm grateful for all of you taking
time on a Saturday to be here that's
pretty remarkable and I did want to
pause and acknowledge like Alisa did
briefly that this is a very special week
so a year ago today we brought mrs.
Reagan to rest here a year ago this week
she passed away and also a year ago this
week it was Ronald I'm Nancy Reagan's
anniversary they were married on March
4th of 1952 so it really is a very
special week of remembrance and I'm
going to share a lot of reflections of
my times and my years working for
President Reagan but before I started
with that I kind of wanted to start with
a little bit about the book itself how
many of you in here have written a book
before or intend to write a book someday
don't be laughing I'm sure there's some
very remarkable students in here okay
CIC who can't for me writing a book was
very much a process of extremes so
writing a book starts with ideas in your
head thoughts in your heart comes
through your fingers onto a keyboard
magic little characters appear on a
screen eventually maybe you get hard
pieces of paper that you put together
with a paper clip or a binder and then
ultimately it winds up like this it's
like a magical incredible process well
because of my experience as the
executive assistant to the president I
was very much used to a role behind the
scenes so I wasn't really even sure how
I felt about writing a book and putting
myself out there in a very visible way I
was just an ordinary girl who happened
to intersect the life of an
extraordinary man and I felt very
grateful for that and at the beginning I
actually tried to write myself out of my
own story should we ever try to do that
we downplay our own story and I
appreciate what my senior editor said to
me he looked at me and he said Peggy not
many people can relate to being
president of the United States but
everybody can relate to a piece of your
story and so you need to tell your story
so I think that everybody who reads this
book can relate to being young and green
and stepping into a place that feels
very foreign and maybe feels way too big
for where you're at in your life and
then hopefully everybody can relate to
that feeling of finding your footing and
all of a sudden realizing that you can
add value and your valuable contributor
in a space that originally seemed very
foreign and then unfortunately for a lot
of us as life goes on we can figure out
a way when life changes when it throws
curveballs at us when things come at us
that we didn't expect our plan or even
want how do we then adjust course how do
we find within ourselves a heroic
strength to go on how do we find balance
in imbalance and choose to live life
joyfully even when it's sometimes tries
to rob us of that by crisis so when
telling my story alongside the president
I want to take you with me I went to get
you to walk into his office with me as
Lisa was talking about and to see what
it was like to travel with him and to go
places with him and to give you a
front-row seat to relive all that I saw
and witnessed during the decade I saw
him and worked with him and on into his
final twilight years through my lens you
will experience the exhilaration of
meeting him for the very first time in
person face to face you'll witness the
outpouring of affection that happened
every time we stepped foot outside the
door how people would respond to him
you'll enjoy star-studded events with
celebrities and world
and savor humorous opportunities and
quiet moments of reflection and
observation you'll also be in the room
when the devastating news about Ronald
Reagan's Alzheimer's disease is
announced in the world and you'll be
part of sharing that heartbreaking news
with the nation you'll get to visit
president mrs. Reagan in their home
during their private years out of the
public eye and you'll even share in the
heartbreaking moment at the president's
bedside when I had to say my final
goodbye to him so in my experiences I
hope that you will find your own and you
will discover that even through pain and
heartache you can produce growth and
confidence in your abilities and
confidence in yourself and realize that
you're stronger than you ever imagined
you'll realize that life is a beautiful
circle and that it can end just as it
began hopeful optimistic full of faith
and love for others and for our great
nation even when it's not the fairy tale
ending that we all wish we could have
those are in part some of the lessons
you will learn from the president will
see you now and the book came out just
about two weeks ago and what an
incredible two weeks it has been I knew
that the conservative Reagan loving flag
waving Patriots would respond to this
book and would have a greater longing to
know more about him and I'm proud to
have been featured in places like the
Washington Times the 700 club American
Rifleman yes I'm an American Rifleman I
never thought I'd see that a non
conservative book club but what I'm even
more thrilled about is that the book has
been featured in places like People
magazine Huffington Post The Today Show
and was even listed as a top must read
book in Harper's Bazaar magazine which
is a ladies fashion magazine
kind of ironic so why all the interest
do you think well I'd like to think it's
a good book but there's much more to it
it's bigger than that
there's a longing for the Reaganesque
values of civility of kindness not just
in our politics but in our society he in
many ways was a symbol for the best of
what we can be collectively and
individually
nation of principled leadership of
optimism vision faith and civility and
confidence in ourselves and in our
United purpose so how did it all begin
I'm gonna take you with me to meet him
right now in his office the first time
that I did I went for an interview in
the office and I know it sounds maybe a
little silly but it never occurred to me
that he might actually work in his
office
and so in all of my preparations for my
interview I planned
you know what would I say how would I
answer the questions I never prepared
myself for meeting Ronald Reagan himself
I just never thought it would happen and
so I will embarrass myself with this
story but it's already out there in
print for the world to see and I hope
you will enjoy it and experience the
exhilaration of meeting this man for the
first time so I was walked out after the
interview was over I was feeling pretty
good about it but I walked out to the
lobby and I was seated in the lobby they
were gonna bring me parking validations
thankfully because I was a starving
college student and I was a worried I
wouldn't even be able to pay to get my
car out of the car the garage so I was
sitting there in the lobby and it says
waiting for my interviewer in the lobby
felt almost like a dream state it was so
foreign to anything I had ever
experienced yet somehow felt strangely
familiar as if it was all meant to be
the door nearest me suddenly swung open
and for Secret Service agents in suits
and ties with earpieces radios and with
guns holstered under their coats walked
hurriedly toward me did they know who I
was did they know what I was doing there
were they gonna shoot me arrest me and
then behind the lead agent I saw two
older gentlemen in golf attire wait was
it could it possibly be it was the
president and his golf buddy Walter
Annenberg in all of my interview prep
and planning it had never occurred to me
I might actually meet President Reagan
and I didn't know what to do so I
thought about what I would do if the
flag were passing by so I stood up
straight placing my hand over my heart
not even looking at him staring nobly
off into the distance I'm certain I
looked completely ridiculous but instead
of walking past me he walked right
toward me he looked me in the eye and
extended his hand I shook his hand and
introduced myself
well hello Peggy it's nice to meet you
said the 40th President of the United
States of America to me I had imagined
him as a 10 foot tall giant after all he
had been a movie star a governor and the
President of the United States he had
tackled communism head-on freed the
dicks the domestic economy and solved
many of the world's problems yet here he
was an ordinary man just over six feet
tall his hair in pictures appeared
jet-black yet up close I saw touches of
gray evidence of his 78 years he was
ruddy and rosy-cheeked full of life
happiness and vitality his smile was
more asymmetrical than I had noticed in
photographs and it was perfect in its
imperfect way and those eyes a wonderful
bright true blue and carrying so much
joy he was gone as quickly as he
appeared taking all the people the
energy and the aura of power and
importance with him the office was
suddenly eerily still Selina my friend
who had interviewed me then walked
through the door through the same door
grinning ear-to-ear having witnessed my
ridiculous salute it's pretty incredible
meeting him for the first time isn't it
you should have warned me I said still
trembling inside no it's much better
this way and though I felt I had
horribly embarrassed myself I had to
agree Selina then handed me the parking
validation stickers and said I was gonna
wait to call you tomorrow and leave you
hanging in suspense for at least a while
but I already know we want you to work
here so can you start interning with us
on Monday yes I could so I held it all
together until I was outside the
building I didn't know whether to shout
for joy cry or drop to my knees in
prayers of Thanksgiving I was so
overwhelmed by all that it just happened
I started laughing
out loud the preposterous nosov it all
me him this office Fox Plaza Avenue of
the stars we had met he had shook my
hand and now I work for him I didn't
have any idea what Monday would hold but
I knew with confidence it would never be
the same after that day and in fact it
had already changed so that's how my
story begins and I consider myself to be
one of the luckiest woman in the world
because I did have a front-row seat to
history I got to see this man up close
behind the scenes when he thought that
nobody was watching when the cameras
weren't rolling but as his executive
assistant my job is always to watch what
he's doing right so I'm gonna take you
behind the scenes and show you a little
what I saw with him what I realized with
him and what you will realize as you're
going through your leadership journey is
a lot of times there's this tendency to
lead in a certain way and live your life
in another way with Ronald Reagan there
was this great consistency he didn't see
those two different sides of the coin
those were the same for him the way you
led and the way he lived were
inseparable
and that was what he always believed and
what he always exhibited I started
working for him in 1989 you ladies can
laugh at the hair style hair styles in
the fashions of the 80s and 90s my
children are horrified but you know
hopefully we keep up with the times
but I started working for him right
after he left office so he returned from
the White House came out to Los Angeles
I started working for him a few months
later I thought I'd be there for a short
period of time as I was graduating
college and at the end of my internship
I was offered a full-time staff position
so I went from being an intern to the
executive assistant to the chief of
staff and I worked in that capacity for
about three years until ronald reagan's
executive assistant he had had for
decades retired and they asked me if i
would take that job well that's not
something you say no to right although I
was six months pregnant with my first
baby it wasn't quite sure how that was
all going to work out my job ran the
spectrum it was a really small staff so
we all wore lots of hats so my job has
everything from meeting a world leader
at the front of the office bringing them
in making sure the meeting was going
well snapping photographs of their
meeting
bringing in their lunch and at the end
maybe even clearing the dishes he kind
of did a little bit of everything I had
to make sure he had cash in his pocket
when he wanted to get his haircut
presidents don't always carry a lot of
cash around make sure he had toothpaste
in his bathroom if he wanted to brush
his teeth and sharpen pencils at his
desk so the job ran the spectrum
anything and everything he made it I
tried to take care of it for him and in
fact tried to anticipate so that he
didn't even have to ask sandy him behind
the scenes I realized that there were
not two Ronald Reagan's exactly who you
saw publicly it was exactly who he was
privately so when we were traveling we
were just an event in a backstage hold
area the same graciousness and warmth
that he put on for the camera was the
same way he's left his like behind the
scenes what a wonderful example of
character and what a great example for
all of us to remember especially in a
leadership role there's always people
around you watching and whether or not
he was conscious of that he was very
much the same person all the time behind
the scenes I loved working for him of
course it was a very difficult very
fast-paced job but what a joy he made it
to work for him
there's so many things I look back on
and you know all the glamorous
star-studded events but it's kind of
ironic that when I look back on what
were my favorite times in all the years
of working for him
and I don't know that you could call
them ordinary days because I don't know
that there's anything ordinary about
being in the president's office but I
look back with great fondness on those
days when it was just the regular
routine days in the office
and were these two very unlikely people
who based on our life experiences and
our ages we were eons apart and yet how
we came together to have a great system
of working things out and accomplishing
things and really enjoying working
together we had a very smooth running
schedule had everything all worked out
together but just this interesting
dynamic of two very unlikely people and
how we work together really well so I
treasure those days in the office of
course there were important days as well
more than others
witnessing historic signatures being
signed onto documents traveling all
across the nation and internationally
but the president was always a thrill
always private air
have to always Secret Service motorcades
you know through intersection control
pretty phenomenal but he made that a lot
of fun getting behind the scenes to see
him that was great
so post-presidency he had a very small
staff and one of my favorite jobs for
him was being his post-presidency
photographer for most of his office
stuff so here I am behind the lens of
the camera and it was great to see this
man when things were really unscripted
so did you ever think about when we have
photographs of private meetings how do
we get those photos when everybody
leaves the photographer stays so I got
to be the ultimate fly on the wall and
watch him interact with everybody from
Lady Margaret Thatcher here he is taking
her through the museum upstairs I'm sure
you guys have all either seen it or will
see it beautiful facility and it's an
honor to be here today in this beautiful
place people like Margaret Thatcher and
I also got to see them behind the scenes
after the events can you relate to this
some of you ladies in your heels yeah
the ladies have their shoes kicked off
and the president if you can see him
it's kind of got his eyes rolled in the
back of his head as if to say come on
can we just go home the end of a long
day even if this man would get tired so
how fun to be able to see them behind
the scenes like this and this looks like
an ordinary enough picture of Ronald we
can see Reagan until you realize that I
snapped this photo right as the elevator
doors were opening and Margaret Thatcher
was stepping out and if you look at
their faces they're like little kids so
happy that their friend is here very
excited and you can just see that coming
through this was a woman that they not
only had a political alliance with but
the president had a personal friendship
with and there's so much I learned about
what diplomacy looks like the Reagan way
from this man Ronald Reagan's version of
diplomacy was not political it was very
personal and it wasn't based on rhetoric
it was based on relationships and I
watched time and time again as world
leaders came to see him post presidency
you have to realize that post presidency
they didn't have to come for protocol or
diplomatic reasons when they came all
the way to Los Angeles to see Ronald
Reagan
it was because they wanted to they had a
relationship with this man that they
wanted to continue long after he was the
office holder he couldn't do anything
for them anymore politically but they
didn't care they liked him as a person
and wanted to continue that relationship
and so post presidency they came
Gorbachev came Prime Minister naka Soni
from Japan how much coal from Germany
prime minister and mrs. Brian Mulroney
from Canada a great dear friend of the
president's president like Melissa I
think symbolically they were trying to
push that wall over right he was a man
of authenticity what you saw was what
you got and as much as he loved the pomp
and circumstances of black-tie events
and going to all these fancy things he
really loved going up to the ranch it
was a man of incredible authenticity he
loved being up there at the ranch and at
have any of you been up to the ranch
it's very small it's very humble a lot
of people would picture this
presidential estate as being this
glamorous retreat it's not that at all
but Ronald Reagan loved it there he
loved taking people there he was never
embarrassed that this little tiny you
know adobe home that started its
foundation in the 1800's was where they
lived when they went up there he'd loved
taking people up there including
Margaret Thatcher he took her up there
although she doesn't look like she's
dressed for ranch activities I think
that was a dress down day for her but
you see the president in his flannel in
his jeans and his belt buckle in his
boots this is who he was he loved being
up there
he wasn't embarrassed to bring Margaret
Thatcher up to a little tiny Adobe home
up at the top of the hilltop in Santa
Barbara
he really came alive there in such a
different way he loved working outdoors
clearing brush chopping trees loved
taking his visitors around this is Brian
Mulroney seeing these two world leaders
bouncing around the back of a secret
service driven suburban was quite
enjoyable they both had Irish heritage
and had these fathers that were great
Irishmen storytellers and so the two of
them would always have this great banter
going back and forth and tell hilarious
stories and mrs. Mulroney was this great
beautiful woman and I overheard when I
was snapping the
picture she looked to mrs. Reagan and
she said Oh Nancy aren't you stylish in
your trendy bootcut jeans which were the
thing at the time and mrs. Reagan looks
at her and said these old things I've
been wearing these since the last time
these weren't in fashion so some of the
things in your closet if you hold on to
him long enough they'll come back around
by the way I was wearing a Burberry
skirt today buddy noticed that at the
beginning we can laugh at all the
clothes but ladies I was wearing
Burberry before anybody so I was ahead
not behind the fashions and when he had
Gorbachev up to the ranch here he is
driving Corbett that's actually
Gorbachev riding shotgun Ronald Reagan
is driving when Ronald Reagan was behind
the wheel of his Jeep you wanted to get
off the road because this man had not
driven in eight years you just didn't
trust his driving really ahead of his
Secret Service detail looks a little
nervous in the backseat but the
president looks like a little kid got
the steering wheel so excited to be
behind the wheel in the car and what
Gorbachev was going to be coming up to
the ranch President Reagan asked me if I
would get a gift for him and decided if
he wanted to give him a Stetson cowboy
hat now he kind of joked tongue-in-cheek
saying it may be tough to find one in
his size since he has such a big head
Gorbachev had just been named Time
magazine man of the year so I didn't
know whether he meant that figuratively
or literally but it turned into this
worldwide quest to figure out what size
cowboy had to score Bichette even where
couldn't exactly google it back in the
day I know now I sound really old
couldn't Google that so I had to stay
late into the night to call his offices
in Moscow the next morning and through
several series of phone calls and faxes
and things finally got a Russian hat
size but then had to convert it to a
Western hat size and it was all the
things I had he wondering if it would
actually work and thankfully when the
cameras were rolling and Gorbachev put
the Hat on it fit perfectly
stress I don't know if you know much
about Ronald Reagan's life story but he
talks about having very humble
beginnings here's a man who was born in
the middle of a snowstorm in the middle
of a Great Depression and a wide spot in
the road in central Illinois why all
accounts you would look at his life
story and say this guy is never gonna go
anywhere the cards were really stacked
against him his father was an alcoholic
they had no money he was in a place that
there was no opportunity and yet Ronald
Reagan was raised by an incredible
mother of faith and she taught him to be
true to his God to serve his community
to care about others she raised him to
believe that God has a plan for everyone
and seemingly random twists of fate are
all part of his plan and in the end
everything will work out for the best so
regardless of the circumstances of his
life how it appeared that nothing
possible good could come from tampico or
Dixon Illinois he was raised by a mother
who always believed that there was a
bigger plan for his life and thankfully
he believed it too now it didn't come
without a lot of hard work but he dared
to dream and he worked hard to pursue it
and he proved he's the ultimate epitome
of the American dream he proved that
anything is possible here in America so
regardless of your circumstances those
don't dictate your future and he
certainly proved that he was known for
being the Great Communicator but I would
say he was also known for being the
great optimist you guys of course don't
remember but your parents would remember
in the 1970s things in America were not
very good taxes were high inflation was
high unemployment was really high I see
a few nodding heads in the back of the
room a lot of this sound familiar here's
the beautiful part about Ronald Reagan
on day one he took office and he started
using language like it's morning in
America there's a new dawn ahead there's
a shining city on a hill and we are all
part of it in reality on Ronald Reagan's
inauguration day not one thing was
different in
America we got our hostages back that
was pretty great but the economy hadn't
changed nothing had changed our taxes
were still higher inflation was still
her employment was still high but Ronald
Reagan changed the game with optimism
and you as future leaders need to
remember optimism makes all the
difference he painted a picture for how
it could be better and people willingly
and eagerly followed him he would be the
first one to say I didn't do great
things during the 1980s
I just got government out of the way so
the people could do great things and
that's what great leaders do everything
changed with a little bit of optimism
and then a really good plan of action
that came in along behind that he was
also a man of humility so when you think
of these people on the world stage and
you think of somebody who was at the
highest pinnacle of their career
I don't know that humility is often a
word that you would think is in sync
with that but Ronald Reagan was a great
man of humility he never felt like he
was better than anybody else he felt
like he was living out his god-given
calling in life and if you were doing
the same we were all equal he kept a
sign on his desk that said there's no
limit to what a man can do or where he
can go so long as he doesn't mind who
gets the credit and that was not just
the sign on his desk that's actually the
way he lived his life there was nothing
above him or beneath him nothing was too
good for him are not good enough for him
he was just a fellow soldier on life's
path there were little ways he would
demonstrate this humility to me cute
little things like he would reach over
and hold my elbow as we would go up and
down the stairs which I don't know if
you gentlemen know that that's the
gentlemanly polite thing to do and I
always thought it was especially sweet
since I was in my 20s and he was in his
80s and he was reaching over to help me
there was another day in the office when
we had brought a bunch of extra
furniture into his office and we had a
big meeting in there and at the end I
was carrying these big heavy wooden and
leather chairs one at a time from the
conference from the office back to the
conference room and I'm one of my trips
back and forth with these big heavy
chairs I felt like somebody was
following me and I turned around and
sure enough there's Ronald Reagan right
behind
carrying one of the big heavy chairs and
I stopped and I said oh it's okay mr.
president I'll come back and get it and
he put that chair down and he stared me
down and he said what makes you think
you can carry a chair any better than I
can okay right this way we carried the
chairs together but he was a very aware
unappreciative of the people around them
and what they were doing on his behalf
he had a great sense of humor if you've
ever read a lot of his jokes and story
if he was the originator of so much of
that humor and it wasn't humor just for
the sake of humor he usually used it to
make a bigger point he also used it to
put people at ease you can imagine how I
felt meeting the president for the first
time when people came to meet him they
were obviously pretty nervous sometimes
and he would often use humor to break
the ice and to put people at ease and
make them comfortable even in big
meetings he would use stories that would
make a very significant point
well maybe using a little humor to do it
so as leaders we need to realize that
humor is an important component now I'm
not saying go run out and buy a joke
book or anything but I'm saying you can
take the role seriously without taking
yourself too seriously Ronald Reagan was